this is a production of Cornell
University from my perspective it's it's
really disheartening when I see on
social media us attack each other and
you know sort of I want this you want
that I value this I value that people
value different things and I look at
social media as trying to shout through
a straw I try to be the most positive
self I can be out there because I can
know I know I can piss and moan with the
best of them
so I really feel like the title of every
talk I give is really just supporting
each other through these challenging
times and it really begins with safety
first I don't know how else to say it I
know all of us operate in an OSHA
regulated environment with regard to
work of protection safety and I see a
lot of the outrage around what's
happening that maybe workers aren't
protected and of course our frontline
health care workers and now our military
and service personnel that are actively
trying to address this issue our job
ought to be to keep them safe as well
and and I take that part as staying home
and serving you guys and everyone else
the best I can from home I'm able to do
it I have the privilege and luxury of
doing that and my jobs to try to support
you guys and our jobs to try to support
those people on the frontlines of this
thing now I'm very pleased that Cornell
Cooperative Extension has had a long
time exams extension disaster education
network this is really the centralized
location for information around safety
issues and updates from the government
that address food agriculture and
horticulture we're going to do the best
we can as an extension service to get
this information make it available to
you and as Carl said at the beginning
this certainly will be something that
you'll get updates to as we keep moving
along now how to address this a golf
right I mean this one there's a big
thing going on here right you know
Massachusetts says no golf Carolina says
golf I am NOT gonna you know engage
myself in what I think about this
everybody has personal opinions about it
my jobs to help you folks manage your
golf courses so
right now New York seems to say
maintenance is okay to be honest I'm not
entirely clear on exactly whether golf's
allowed I know State Park Golf sir
golf is open but there probably are a
lot more people up to date on this than
I can but whether there's golfers or not
has an enormous impact on a number of
things right number one if you're a
mom-and-pop operation if you're not
having golfers you got money to pay
people restaurants are struggling with
these things so you know not be an open
has both an economic and a social
consequence as well but not being open
from a grass growing perspective
provides enormous opportunities if it's
deemed safe to work now Massachusetts
golf is open but they haven't decided if
maintenance is is allowable they want to
approve that on a case-by-case basis and
again we can take the discussion about
whether it's safe to go to work and take
care of the grass again personally I
have one opinion about it as a scientist
I have an opinion about it but from a
turf perspective that's not my decision
if somebody's telling you to go to work
or if you guys are making decisions to
go to work this is the problem the
patchwork of rules and regulations make
it challenging to have a hundred percent
confidence in any decision you make I've
already accepted that and in science we
live in the world of probability so
right now if you want normal confidence
in all your decisions you're gonna have
a really tough time my sense is having a
hundred percent confidence and so I
would argue that the message to all of
you at the get-go is you got to use data
and non bias resources to develop a
strategic plan for your facility that
addresses the potential various levels
of restrictions what happens if you
can't go and cut the grass what happens
if you can't spray your seed heads what
happens if you can't do that now the
interesting thing is I spent my entire
career studying what happens if you
don't do things so it's been very
interesting for me to now draw on
research of things I've done for the
last 25 years and of course my
colleagues across the country that are
doing science as well are giving us good
information about that so with that as a
backdrop
and safety is first tomforde you got a
love top forward tom must have worked in
landscape business I don't know Tom Ford
but if you have the chance to review
these this is a great place to start
certainly there are more detailed ones
more golf specific ones you should have
once of course for your facility but
what I like about what Tom does this
here he goes into a lot of the cultural
aspects of a landscape a green industry
workforce you know we are the kind of
people that in generally are introverted
we want to be out there and about by
ourselves but at the same time we do
congregate a lot right and and lunch
rooms and and we have other cultures
working in our systems that also
congregate and finish each other's
lunches and do other things with people
Tom addresses this in a really nice
fashion as much as it pains me to say
anything nice about the old PSU this is
absolutely one of the best places to
start for understanding what your
workplace is going to be confronting now
let's get the grown grass here's what we
know this is from the National phenology
Network there's a people that monitor
you know the progression of the growing
season in the continental United States
and they have people reporting these
things from across the United States and
right now from a biological and plant
perspective you can see the number of
states and part of the United States
that are well ahead 20 days ahead of
normal relative to the spring index
anomaly that they use for leafing out
and you can see in the mid part of the
country Kansas the panhandle of Oklahoma
Colorado that may be the southern
reaches of Nebraska even a little bit 20
days behind normal but overall
everybody's ahead this is a big
challenge as we have to scale back what
we're doing now let's just look in New
York our forecast website has a lot of
data that I would encourage you to use
because you're going to need this data
to explain to people who you service
what's going to happen if you can't do
certain things or what's going to happen
if you have this scale back now although
this doesn't matter if you're bringing a
crew at 10 or a crew at 8 to come in and
cut the girl
yes I mean there's a lot of things
you're gonna find you can do without the
offers around how productive and quick
you move through the place when there's
nobody around you don't have to change
cups you're not to move to tees it's a
very different work environment but the
natural world is pushing the biological
world along pretty dramatically soil
temperatures are a good place to start
they govern a lot so if you're in the
Connecticut River Valley for example or
in the Hudson Valley
you see some of that growth starting to
sneak sneak up that salt temperature
started sneaked up the Hudson Valley and
certain anybody listening from Jersey
and South Philly and South is already
sort of moving along in this area now
let's start with the Big Woods mole
water fertilized pasts things like that
I'll start with my pal Bill Chrysler
Doug sold out I know Bill is with us
this morning to talk a little bit about
this greenkeepers going to also be doing
some webinars but this little graph that
bill did a number of years ago when he
was studying primo growth regulation at
different rates at different heights of
cut really was the origin of a lot of
the thinking around collar decline and
how growth regulators work based on the
mowing height and essentially all this
graph is showing you is that independent
of growth regulator use if you look at
where the growth intersects where
there's no growth regulator applied
right here on the axis you'll see that
the higher you cut right the higher you
mow your grass the lower clipping
production you're generally getting the
higher you mow the greater clipping
production so there's no question about
it from a grass growth perspective if
you mow higher you'll produce less lower
growth rate and and don't kid yourself
growth rate is the whole deal pop and I
was between an eighth of an inch and the
red line and a quarter of an inch so
we're not talking about 500 or 750 this
is a quarter of an inch increase to go
from to see that that big of a change in
growth
so you know even small changes or even
skipping mowings we know slows the
growth rate down so those things are
things that can be helpful that's right
and I think you said in the thing I was
reading that you're working on that if
you raise it this much that's a 40%
reduction in growth is that's what this
graph is showing essentially right bill
yeah I wouldn't say you know you go from
a putting green height to a quarter of
an inch but it would be it's a small
increase you know the higher we go the
slower though like mowing height starts
to slow down so even small increases in
in mowing height you know can really
help to alleviate that
so that growth rate down and so I'm
gonna show your graph and you're here
and I just want to show it so that as we
begin to need growth regulators when I
recommend using data this is the kind of
data you're going to have to be clearer
about bill but I don't want to waste
another minute
here's your app and I certainly want to
encourage people to use this way of
looking at their data but here's my
summary on mowing rapidly as we keep
trying to move this along number one
don't rush to mow check your growth I
think I would start at a higher height
right away if you haven't started mowing
why not you know let it grow higher as
bills days rolling particularly at the
putting green level now we could have a
different discussion about the fairway
height but a putting greens if those are
deemed to be the ones you're going to
care for the most and send people in on
a regular basis I think you should maybe
consider top dressing right now to allow
the canopy to fill because if we have to
let this thing go a little bit longer
and we want to come back in and drive to
drive the height down to make it
playable again and whoever knows how
long having that base built up is also
going to help you lower the height more
effective effectively and then I
recommend using PRP gr strategically and
then I think there's a lot more to come
on this now bill since I got you what
would you say about raising Heights on
fairways which is if you're normally at
50 and you got Bank grass fairways or
Poe of fairways would you
no point seven-five you know I don't
know if I see that if you're gonna bent
or bent pole I don't know if I really
see the reduction in growth rate from
going from you know 500 to 750 so I
don't know from a slowing growth can we
see the perspective but if it does mean
that you can stretch out your mowings
because you're able to abide by the
one-third rule better then you know that
makes that become a lot more attractive
than one sort of an option there so
right if you leave it out of higher
height then to follow the one-third rule
your letting more growth occur before
you come back exactly in simple terms so
so let's talk about PG RS right here
billing I know you're gonna talk more
about this in your green keeper seminar
with Doug today and I know you've got a
publication plan we seem a little bit
early here in the Northeast to really
get these growth regulator programs
going however my big question around
this is why couldn't I go out at a high
rate if I've dreamed up a willing to let
some phyto toxicity to occur to maybe
get a month or three weeks of
suppression is that a crazy idea or is
it something that's feasible
I think it's feasible especially if
there's not a lot of traffic the golf
courses are closed you know we we've
been able to do a significant amount of
toxicity and our research on purpose and
we've been yet to actually kill you know
the bank grass maybe the poet wouldn't
be able to like it if we did it really
aggressively with some of the PG ours
I'm not even gonna say it's a trim it
heartless thing it's all about how much
suppression you're getting so the trim
it just gives you about double the
amount of suppression at the label rate
that primo doesn't so one of the reasons
that you get more risk of photo is you
just get more growth suppression with it
exactly and so you know it comes back to
we need growth to handle and recover
from traffic and where and if we don't
have much travel occur where and we can
tolerates a little bit of discoloration
then fine
and so those growth rates down and so
doing an application now I think if the
foliage is not greened up like here in
Nebraska everything just goes Brown so I
don't know how much say Primo or new May
got Maine I didn't get into the plant
with all that brown foliage there so
maybe you need to look at a cutlass or a
trim it to try to get some root up takes
it to really get some benefits out of
those products so if people are doing
proxy with their primo apps right now
for seed heads usually I'd say don't put
the pgrn on the first app until the
growth rate starts to go to normal but
maybe that's not the right decision in
this scenario because we actually don't
want that growth rate we do want to be
slowing down and so going out of that
application might help and when it comes
to those repeat applications to say
proxy I know I'm some of the guys at
Bayer now are saying to also apply on
the 200 growing degree day window that
we use for primo so instead of just
going every two weeks look at your
growing degree days and then make even
those second and third proxy
applications based on the same growth
rate in PG hours that you would be doing
for for for your your primo so what
about I mean if in my mind I lost my
train of thought so so so so let me let
me I lost my train of thought bill he
was so good I was so engaged I totally
lost my train of thought there I guess
I'm wondering are you saying honestly
that if I put a pretty high rate of trim
it on my temp bampo or fairways because
I don't think I'm going to be able to
mold him for a while
they might look nasty but they're gonna
be fine over time yeah I mean it's I
would say that we've we've sprayed it a
lot I'm not too worried about it the POE
is gonna be pretty healthy if it is if
it survived and ready to grow out
anyways it's a good time of year for it
you know the poem I'm more worried about
the the trim it really hurting poem when
it's warm when it can't make those
sterols that are important for heat
tolerance and so if we're in the spring
and I was concerned and when it comes to
a growing degree day approach an event
or a bed pull off fairway the interval
for trim it is like 450 to 600 grow
degree days that's like a six six or
seven weeks oppression window and so you
can try to get more suppression out of
that let me ask you about when to start
normally I would start when the grass
would resume normal a kind of normal
girl for that I would consider healthy
if I'm looking at this now when you're
starting to see that gross with the push
out of the crown that's probably when I
would start the application I don't know
if I'd waste time applying to grass
that's if you're still really cold and
your soils are still in the 40s and
you're not getting any real growth yet I
don't think I would go just yet
unless there's going to be potential
that you can't be on your golf course
because it's close then you wouldn't
maybe even make that application if the
soils are cold and we don't get like
inches of rain that trim it should hang
out in the soil and it should you know
transpired so last question before I
move to the next thing what about the
other things we apply that have
regulating properties a lot of guys want
to get their presiding about summer
patch suppression or diem early season
diem is I'm gonna get to that but since
we're talking about growth regulation
I'm wondering about the other things
that we use and that sort of stacking
effect you sometimes talk about that
overall when we have traffic might be a
bad thing
but now might be a good thing again do I
have to worry about overdoing it and
killing yes I mean duck soil looks like
he's on now too and he just said he's
done recently saw a 10x rate of trim it
with no real ill effects you know he's
not worried about overdose and the
absence of traffic and I would agree
there too and so when it comes to that
stacking effect that's something we have
in greenkeeper now I've just built this
new model that starts adding all those
products together so we have DM eyes we
have all the the PTR's
and instead of looking at products
individually like product Primo's giving
me 20% trim has given me 30% we start
adding those suppression points together
so the amount of total suppression is 50
and so what we're trying to do is start
adding everything together again
five percent from a BMI forty percent
here and it does obviously tail off you
can't have a hundred and twenty percent
suppression but the model accounts for
that and so those are one of the things
that we can actually do say we're trying
to get more suppression on our greens
and we know a trim it at the high rate
which i think is sixteen ounces per acre
and Premo out the label array which is
five ounces per acre I'm getting you
know 15 or 20 percent suppression out of
my primo and I'm getting 40% suppression
on the trim it there I'm getting that 50
60 % suppression in total and when it
comes to the amount of suppression again
that's relative so if your growth rate
is really very slow then it's gonna be
really really slow but if you start
getting into we're seeing that spring
surge of growth you might need 60 70 80
percent suppression to really keep your
clipping yields where they want to be it
go along with that this isn't some of
our research you know we've been pushing
some of our research greens with you
know really high rates and I shouldn't
fertilizer and then to try to suppress
the growth rate back down to a normal
level we would go put down 10x rates of
primo and have zero photo toxicity
because at the end of the day the amount
of grass in our bucket is normal then if
you're using low rates of fertilizer and
no PGR and so the risk of Fido seems
much more highly right now correlated to
what the absolute amount of clippings in
the bucket is and not what the rate is
I see you've joined there Carl can we
give Doug camera and see if he wants to
add anything before you move on here I
can let him use the camera but yeah good
morning no nothing nothing on PGR is I'm
just starting to think about nitrogen
and you know this is an opportunity well
I guess I should say a little bit about
gujjars I think I hear a lot of people
use PG ours on fairways and I say well
how does it reduce your mowing and I say
I don't know we sold all three days a
week so this is an opportunity to see
how things work you know try something
new
reduce the reduce the maintenance a bit
I've just been thinking about nitrogen
management a bit here I'm not sure if
we're gonna head down that road soon
let's do it but we're here now we're
here now because my thoughts were again
right now why would you apply nitrogen
here's my question that I'm gotta
believe people have to be asking
themselves if you don't have golfers why
on earth would you be applying nitrogen
right now it's my first question gave
you worried about diseases and other
sorts of things I could you're gonna get
a lot of growth stimulation from evening
applying it why apply it exactly and
this is something that I've been
thinking about last couple years is you
apply nitrogen to recover from damage
and to hit a growth rate and right now
we're trying to reduce a growth rate
there is no reason if you're if you
don't have golfers out there there's no
reason to think about putting nitrogen
down and I know it's something we do
almost every week it becomes a reflex
right and so that's what I want people
think about right now is get rid of
those reflexes this is a completely
different time and nitrogen should be
the last thing you should be thinking
about right now regret it's gonna get it
from the soil you're gonna miss oils got
plenty of nitrogen in it to keep the
grass alive right you don't need to
repair any and a traffic damaged and I
guess the only thing I'll add and Carl
you brought this up is is raising the
mowing height on putting greens just
consider this for a second if you all of
a sudden started to you know we're able
to raise them up to a quarter inch
imagine that I mean I wouldn't imagine
oakmont's gonna do it but other places
that might say try to you know make
their way through this might try to do
that just think about the pink positions
you can put on sloped areas how much of
the surfaces we've lost over the years
in the last 40 50 years because of the
way we've been mowing so for those
people that stay open and stay out there
I would still encourage you to lower
your mowing height and maybe add some
difference in interest as Doug saying
just change your perspective a little
bit on things you have to look at things
a little bit differently and certainly
mowing and growth as a place to start so
I want to try to keep as best I can and
I know there's tons of questions so guys
I'm gonna get the weeds now and I'm
gonna get through a lot of this stuff
pretty quick primarily because I think
we're a little bit early we have good
data on when it's time to apply your
seed head suppression now of course
you'll already done it in the fall
you're locked in and I would reiterate
what Doug said if you're gonna go out
I'm sorry what bill said if you go on
out what your proxy normally we wouldn't
tell you to put the Primo in there but
at this time when you're really trying
to shut down growth and you don't have a
lot of traffic then that would be the
time to get that higher primo in there
right bill I want to make sure I got
this right if I go out my proxy in a
normal way as our recommendations are I
can increase my primo or would you even
tell me maybe put trim it in there yeah
you're limited on your you know what the
label will allow so that's still still
comment on those confines and you're not
going that much suppression of the
premium oh and again if the grass really
isn't greening up very much I don't know
how much uptake we're seeing so maybe
using trim it and if you're worried
about that remember that a 4 ounce rate
of trimming will give you about the same
amount of suppression of the biobalance
rate of primo but for entre to trim it
seems low to everybody you guys talking
about that's a 6 is a low rate well yeah
that's a 6 or 7 ounce rate of primo and
so if you're using 4 ounces in treatment
you're still gonna get about 20 percent
suppression out of it just like you
would have got not into that Primos so
for that first app if you're a little
leery then that's fine if you're gonna
make repeated applications of proxy
though you could do the pre model still
and then on your second app go proxy
trim it to minimize that and from a
final perspective and we've mixed the DM
eyes and the class B's like trim it with
some of the green pigmented products
we've really minimized that
discoloration so you've really are
concerned about that phyto when you make
those apps if you include like we're
testing it with with the bear or stress
guard pigment and we were really able to
show that the fight electricity was
substantially less disick allele s by
just including those pigments with those
treatment applications copper has a
known safe inning effect on some
phytotoxic responses it is the reason
the pigment is in Civitas is because
that phytotoxic response from the oil is
minimized when you're using copper it's
not masking it right bill it's it's
preventing it yeah it definitely
prevents it and and so we've seen that
and when we're looking at density and
things actually see
the green color effect or if it's so
safe inning it really did seem like even
with the class BPG ours that the you
know density was still good and
everything seemed to be you know healthy
so if you're worried about Fido
including some of those those copper
based pigments can really help to
minimize that risk perfect okay what
about crabgrass again in the Northeast
it's certainly by the GDD tracker
hopefully you're using this tool for as
one of your data tools your gdb tracker
is telling you in the metropolitan New
York area
it looks ideal for crabgrass control as
you move beyond you know and I wonder
how many landscapers are out there doing
this it's obviously time it feels a
little early still as you can see in
upstate New York with the yellow and the
cream-colored a lot more time to the
further northeast but the crabgrass
germination still seems a little ways
away to me based on the soil temperature
data that we still see in the 40s when I
know I got to be almost in the 60s to
get pretty good crabgrass germination so
there is some indication to get this
down and again if you're not going to be
able to get out there in a while and
this is something you want to do go
ahead and do it I'm a little bit with
Doug there's a part of me that I would
be curious to see what would happen if I
didn't do this but I think for those of
you trying to support a business and
clients this might still be the safe way
to go I think we've got time and then
you've got to decide what weeds will be
an issue right now you're going to see
winter annual weeds everywhere and if
they start flowering it doesn't make
sense they go out and spray them I think
our perspective on a lot of things
that's going to change dramatically if
this lockdown continues and and if it
gets more severe I think we're still
easy early for water as Doug said in
nitrogen management you know if the
waters not moving through the plant as
you can see here this is this is the
excess water that we have throughout
much of the northeastern United States
we have slight deficits in the most
northern places but in general right now
with the Sun angle and the cloudy
weather and the rain we've been having I
don't think too many people are thinking
about water and I would even caution
people don't be in a rush to get it
fired up what happens if we get cold
again
and you've got water in those pipes and
we get down into the 20s especially in
upstate New York so I wouldn't be in a
rush necessarily to get this going and
again for disease I asked Bill earlier
about the DMI drenches a lot of guys are
gonna be thinking about their early
summer patch sprays particularly on
annual bluegrass spotting greens
looking at the GDD tracker was still
early for those dollar spot applications
and if you think about the summer patch
models the 55 and 65 degree triggers
we've got a little ways until that
happens now we are expected to be normal
temperature moving forward so we may
have a couple of weeks yet so again keep
this in mind if you're talking to people
about what's essential you have a little
time but if you have to prepare for not
being able to get in this could get
worse Ben McGraw made a pretty strong
statement yesterday about a BW z-- that
I heard pretty loud and clear and I'm
sure you're going to hear more from him
and a lot of other folks while we're all
locked down and I think it's still too
early in fact what Ben said clearly is
if you're going out there trying to get
adults you're probably knocking down
more beneficial insects than you are the
actual pests you're trying to control so
I would urge you right now in the
metropolitan New York area and in places
where annual bluegrass weevil is a
particular problem to get if you're
there get out and look around get some
lemon joy so look at the videos on
scouting that Steve McDonald has done
the resources that are out there get
data don't just do things the way you've
always done them because they've always
worked that way we're in a very
different environment right now where
you have to be more strategic and
tactical about the things that you're
doing and allowed to do and
communicating that to your people that
you work for is absolutely going to be
critical now that's all I wanted to say
as far as formal presentations Carl so
I'm gonna stop sharing my screen so we
can look at each other and see if
there's questions while we get going
here so where do we want to go well I
think we got most of the questions the
only one I saw was what what is a high I
think
no other questions that I see yeah
unless anybody else any of the
participants you got any burning
questions send them through real quick
and I'll just no dog while you're
putting that together Karl I didn't put
a lot in there on nutrition Doug and and
it's because I actually don't think it's
really much we should be thinking about
for the next couple of weeks but I could
be out in left field on this
what would you say be on nitrogen
because you know you know how things
work you know maybe we need some calcium
might need a little bit of boron get
things going and I'm just a little
nervous that you know the concern we
have for our economy is going to drive
us to you know try to do things that are
going to have virtually no value
can you speak for a minute a little bit
about that yeah you know it's a it's a
good opportunity to to see what happens
under under minimal fertility management
I think you know fertilizer programs are
one of the most inflated over managed
aspects of the course and so now what
I'm recommending is you just stop all
fertility and you're gonna be fine at
the end of this right so it's gonna it's
going to help you be a more efficient
manager now you know you got anthracnose
on you you got a lot of annual bluegrass
you might you got to pay attention your
potassium level still and what we've
known from weaning kuso is that the best
way to get potassium levels up in a plan
is to put a little bit of nitrogen down
with it so when you're using a you know
you want to get something other than
nitrogen into the plant you have it
helps to put a little bit of nitrogen
down to but in general most places
aren't going to need any any inputs
through this period yep so there is a
question about nitrogen relating to
certain diseases so anthracnose is one i
think we've seen nitrogen rates though
down over the last couple years and at
least which luckily will tell us
anthracnose risk going up are you
worried at all about certain diseases
and low nitrogen or is that something
that we're gonna have to wait for for
more summer conditions summer drought
stress to see yeah you know most of my
I'm a bank grass guy right so so
a lot of my bias is there I would say
though you're probably not going to see
as much in track notes if you're raising
the mowing height you're mowing less
frequently you don't have golfers out
there so you know you're gonna see
differences there I wouldn't say hey we
got it we got to get on top of this and
do all the normal and fertility
practices to minimize anthracnose
I just don't see that happening well
you're gonna see is more bent grass come
in you're gonna see a new bluegrass it's
knocking at your inulin gonna die but
it's gonna lose the competitive fight
and you're gonna at the end of this if
you if you're a bent poem Ickx and you
go no fertility you're gonna have more
bent grass and less traffic is also
going to favor the bank grass that's the
reason the annual bluegrass is more
competitive absolutely so I guess I
guess it's important
that's a great question about
anthracnose but remember now anthracnose
you need a lot of the nitrogen sometimes
based on what they do at rutgers because
they stress those things to the point of
death I mean a lot of the research
that's come out of Rutgers has been on
plots where they know they get it when
they stress the turf so I think
inherently a couple of things are going
on one is there may be some latent
anthracnose from last year there was
some discussion of that early on that
might be lingering and waiting to come
on but I think in general again without
a lot of other stress a lot of the
plants will grow themselves out of this
but we've starting to get some really
good questions I want to stick on the
growth thing for a second Carl here's
our concerns with higher trim it rate
and potential frost bill what do we know
about PG R's applied before some frost
comment still yeah I mean I've heard
that and we know we've seen it what
we've heard reports but I'd make a lot
of applications early in the year with
pgrn and proxy and you know sometimes
I'll see kind of a discoloration that
can occur and it's nothing that's lethal
maybe it may be that the leaf tips you
would kind of mow it off you know it's
not like an n/bar where you see that
grass just go completely yellow like he
would have saw with with that so I you
know I think is a concern but again if
we're
trying to suppress growth rate which is
minimize maintenance then it's something
that I can live okay so listen here's a
good question about rough height from
John how you doing John down in Maryland
looking at raising the height to four
inches drive routes and water needs
reduce mowing any concerns on chopping
it back to two as long as it's not hot
my first question is John if you take it
from 4 to 2 I think Bill's gonna tell
you you might increase the growth rate
bill if you violate the 30% rule hasn't
your work showed you get a faster growth
rate I think the thing is a little
deceiving was we thought that this the
growth it was faster until we stopped
not mowing all year long and then we
measured the total biomass and realize
that actually mowing itself at the
one-third rule slows the growth rate
down it's a natural growth inhibition so
by staying at the one-third rule you are
minimizing the number of moles you have
to do and for by producing the lowest
growth rate if you start going to you
know to more frequent mowing than that
your growth rate is still the same speed
but now you're just mowing unnecessarily
more frequently so if you go up to the
four inches which is a great
recommendation because then you can
really stretch out your 1/3 rule to mow
when you're at say six inches this is to
bring it down you just would start to be
a little bit more maybe mowing to the
quarter rule and start slowly bringing
those numbers down but I don't see any
reason that as long as you don't hack it
from four to two which I assume that
they weren't going to do anyways but if
you bring it back down with time you
went see that problem I think we can
learn something from homeowners here too
because most homeowners do scalp it down
and if you do it occasionally especially
if it's only been high for you know a
couple weeks you don't see that
scalpings once that grass has really
become accustomed to being at four
inches and then you don't get as much
for synthetic leaf tissue lower that
when you remove it to two it looks
yellow so if it is a really short term
thing and you may not even see that much
of a detriment from just cycle one time
you know six weeks eight weeks thing
then if we let it do that all year long
and then we scalped it down so that's
actually right I mean these are things
we've never really thought of and here's
Cochrane in the capital district he's
got 27 holes maybe one guy heights to
cut minimum spray programs and he asks
the question about air fication
and I'll just take this time to say um I
don't really think why would you Arif I
mean I'm not sure why I mean Doug am I
crazy
you're a soil physical property guy
we're not going to get traffic is there
a reason why you think we need to
regularly air fie these surfaces or core
cultivate these surfaces in the spring
right now I mean so I think the approach
is like I said earlier nothing should be
a reflex right so that I can think of
good reasons to do it you know if you
got a high organic matter levels and you
want to make some some big changes put
the big cores out there fill them with
sand do some work but but if it's a
party or your normal routine that's not
good enough anymore so you got to think
what is the point of this practice does
it make sense or not and I think you
think people are gonna be all over the
board on that yeah I think it is
important to not be reflex and your make
a good point if you're gonna do it by
all means if you've taken the risk to go
to work and you're doing everything you
can you have an opportunity to do
certain things that you might not have
at other time so again your reflex
action might be good but then you make
an adaptation to say wow you know I got
a lot more again I got five percent
organic matter it would be nice to get
these things down maybe I should get
those three quarter inch hollow tines
out because I don't care if I screw them
up now you know for putting conditions
for a while so that's a really good
question about era fication now
interesting question about leaving
clippings on the green and so what do
you guys think about that
not physically removing the clippings if
you really don't have to play so I
maintain back there putting greens since
I was 15 right so I'm used to like not
having a more everyday
liova last year or so long at 80 so I
still have my normal golf high
expectation but one of the things I
always do is return the clippings
you know once it's dry doesn't stick to
the ball you don't even know they're
there especially if golf is low and you
don't want to fertilize get that
that in there and when it comes to you
know with Molly no skipping mowings
people are doing clipping volumes if
you're doing clipping volumes and you're
skipping your Moe's every other dime or
even maybe every two days and you mow
every third day especially the growth
rates are slow you're gonna notice a
year total cumulative growth rate is
gonna be less over that year because
you're not mowing in every single day
and stimulating that putting green
response that you showed early on so I
would leave the clippings on there is a
source of nutrient so you don't have to
fertilize unless you growth is starting
to get high and maybe you want to slow
down then you could take them off but I
wouldn't if it's good from a labor
perspective if it's gonna continue to
slow things down you can just get out
there and just mow greens and then just
be done and then skip it for three days
like that's fast and easy and it's
getting the job done and that's the way
I would approach it yeah and not picking
up clippings raising the high to cut
three days where does rolling fit in
Bill when I know that you know in the
transition zone Bank grass greens
particularly to transition zones arakan
showed pretty clearly that you can you
know skip you know alternate mowing and
rolling that way I've always felt
rolling would sort of save me some
mowing and also give me some traffic you
know I think one of the things you don't
think about but but done mentioned
without traffic we're gonna have more
Bank grass there might be a valued and
not mowing but rolling sometimes what is
that going to do to growth at the early
stages here bill but done so I was
reading the pant I was reading the
Quebec questions I'm sorry yeah I was
type it on the panel yeah absolutely I
mean and why why do you have to roll you
just skip a mowing right and I guess I'm
wondering about the value my place for
putting a little traffic there's a final
question here about top dressing thus
and working its way into the canopy if I
raise the height of cut am I going to
have
or organic matter accumulation yeah
that's a good thing when you guys are
talking about the the the study you
showed the study the collar height
versus a putting green height we talked
about that earlier so when we when we
ended that study we had big problems
with those collar because it was all in
a green we had problems with those
collar height plots when we tried to
bring them back down to mowing height so
I'm not a huge fan I'd say if you're at
like 120 go up to 140 150 but don't be
bringing your greens up to collar height
at this time because you're gonna have
organic matter issues are gonna have
sponginess so you know keep things
reasonable do these little tweaks but
don't don't do massive changes like that
I don't think so mowing greens doesn't
take that long right so I just don't I
don't like that I don't like making a
massive change like that
right now I think we're gonna be through
this we're gonna be playing golf this
season so I would try to keep I try to
tweak things rather than massive change
okay
what's the effective growth regulators
if you are worried about the root and
the organic matter buildup is that going
to have an effect how is that going to
affect a root growth I guess the
question we're looking at
from a PGI perspective if you do have
very severe phyto toxicity and I mean
that grass is purple you will see a root
crooner now seen it with every single
PVR I've seen it with primo and trim it
and cut lists are not cutlass primo
heavenly tests couples that much but a
new primo and trim it will all do it and
it's just again you have way too much
suppression and so you don't need to
have that much suppression when you're
starting to see some fight oh that's
usually means like that grasses you know
about as slow as you want it to be
growing and they're like a dug put in
the chat before you take the traffic
away and we get into some good weather
here to grow roots when it's nice and
warm and warming up here I think that
the routing issue is not really a
concern when we're getting so many
stresses by alternating mowing and
rolling returning clippings and all
those such things so I really wouldn't
get too caught up just by managing
healthy turf system it's gonna naturally
push good routing and and and and I
wouldn't worry about which with the PGR
unless you're really like severe red eye
if you see me give a talk you've seen
some slides in which that grass is like
like he's painted red and that would be
a problem but if you're seeing some
minor levels of Fido that's something I
would be concerned about excellent so
Carl there's only one last comment here
it's about the sort of essentiality of
things and you know we're not really
getting into too much of what the
government is trying to do about what's
essential and not we're trying to stay
focused on the on you know what are the
impacts of this on grass and we're so
fortunate to have old pals like Doug and
Bill around that are absolute experts in
this area because as Doug says we can't
be reflexive but we should be able to
think through these problems if we use
data and a little bit of science to get
us through and I'm hoping as Doug says
that we'll be playing golf yet this
season one